c'est dans cette ferme en haute-saône
que tout a commencé en 2009 lui sous
l'arbre une thérapeute de 50 ans il
fonde une petite communauté
elle invite ses anciens patients à y
investir leur temps et surtout leur
argent tous travaillaient dans ses
jardins bio sans toucher de salaire
celle qui se dit inspirée par un ange
est aujourd'hui poursuivi pour abus de
faiblesse et travail dissimulé
face à elle quatorze personnes se sont
finalement constituer partie civile
en mars dernier l'ex thérapeute adepte
des méthodes alternatives toujours
présumée innocente ne s'était pas
présenté au procès une chaise vide
difficile à comprendre pour les victimes
c'est bien la preuve que c'est une
manipulatrice elle nous a fait attendre
six ans pour en arriver là maintenant et
c'est franchement non c'est inadmissible
le préjudice total est estimé à 3 135
mille euros le procès devrait durer
trois jours
celle qui est présentée comme un gourou
exerçant une emprise psychologique sur
la communauté encourt jusqu'à cinq ans
de prison